welcome to this video it is a very
strong opponent with is really low
rating for his standards this Grand
Master um um nah my mommy daughter I
think our off Mammadov yeah yeah I don't
think this is this is true ways a bit i
would i know but he's 26 80 or something
and he's still playing this mmm really
rubbish line which probably does not
matter as i'm playing really badly at
moment but ok let's see what happens
yeah it's really low rated for his
standards some normally very clean very
high rated in online blitz okay so we
get this stone ball structure in a
really really good firm a good version
for white i have what
yeah whatever I have never seen this
idea which it looks totally strange to
me but maybe an maybe it's okay i don't
know it looks very strange to me to open
the center when you are not developed
and half those the bed peace 97 and all
bonds are weak but what do I know so I'm
going to take here you're guessing sorry
yeah you are threatening to take n play
Bishop a 6 probably I'm not quite sure
if this was a real threat but it could
easily be the case ok i will Bishop c4
looks normal Queenie form yeah maybe
Queenie form
yeah but your key ones in certainly not
a bad news
yeah if i move the bishop he once played
when you form may be prepared that it
takes rook takes them while my rooks are
really quick in the center he's got them
Bishop on b7 now which is now an active
piece but still I didn't really see a
good term square for the Bishop Bishop
c4 yet Queenie form so i guess i take
with the rook yeah you already see that
he's a very tactically focused player
rook c8 probably a good move young
rookie 5 Roxy to leave some very active
so probably don't want to do that cooing
here interesting yeah maybe this I know
it should be for coming on okay I'd like
to put it here anyway in the night
you always had the option to take it
okay yeah Luke d7 looks very normal but
this looks it too cunning but I have
Queen d60 I mean this with Queenie 7
this must be must be good for for me
right 26 looks like a threat now queen d
67 and this would really kill em on g7
ask winners face a bit off site I mean
maybe maybe I cannot cannot use it
immediately but they are 26 what are you
playing on queen to d6 and tending 27
will create or something like that
there's also Queen deform good looking
at g 7 which is not bad really yeah I
think I do that I don't really see what
he should do against that
Queenie 7i I cannot detect my Ruca or
threaten something directly don't don't
see it at least I only see rookie ATM
and after that even Rock g7 assam comes
into consideration yeah brooktree 727
check there is no made probably well
it's very close maybe there is a mate
okay that's something else I can do here
I mean if I'm very close close to making
a mangy 7 I just need to get the Queen
to e5 and this is not defensible sorry
how can I I do that I know my voice is
really killing me let's there a way to
to get this in Queenie five I don't see
em where I should move the night to get
the Queen to e5 mmm we had yeah man you
know 96 maybe intending 97 and and queen
d 40 Queen D for us high bar is 0 sse
five okay
wait wait wait wait wait um I have I
have I have a move that happens hadn't
seen before you mean I have Queen f7 f60
if you get the King to h6 check
I always thought that km/h six is the
problem but I have Queen f7 threatening
Queen f68 check I can go to age five
year as sick as it looks you can go to
age five
oh let's desire totally overlooked ok ok
still Queen chief I've made
I don't I don't see if I win at the
moment unfortunately check this is a
draw check oh this is a double check
waiting on that and really out of shape
I mean I take ages to see to movers yeah
night f7 is medium checkmate wow what a
game it was probably an ok game but I
really take ages to see the simple stuff
yeah that while the whole opening line
is Sun has already set a number of times
a bit strange for black but he played it
very interestingly with with night a 6
yeah I probably should play a 3 this is
not bad and then you just went c5 it
looks it looks a bit strange to open up
the position here but yeah it that has
it has some point with this b6 idea
maybe I'm he should even consider to
take first then d6 and we're not sure
how bad this boss Knight takes Queen
takes rook ft-1 look fd1 given by the
computer why not rook ad one or two spot
is better in comparison interesting I
don't know
played Bishop be services I really don't
understand at the moment why we ft one
should be any better yeah computer wants
to play Bishop c4 with the big edge I've
Quincy 10 I didn't really see Quincy one
which is not terribly difficult to see
but with rook everyone coming and then
I'm very nicely placed down okay I
didn't see that so I loud the capture
and well around here he probably starts
to go wrong I mean maybe I'm it is
simply simply to off side of the Queen
tough
maybe to see form yeah but how good he
here Bishop g5 yeah maybe just trying to
to block the default this is certainly
better than what he did my computer is
still giving white a very nice edge I'm
click on the see if I am and the 85 is
also a good piece the bishop on d5 is
certainly am quite good but the night is
also not bad you haven't this probably
after Bishop g7 white is winning out
okay and queen d 6 is right and here
Queen D for as strongest you know I had
the slight suspicion that this was a
strong move but tough check this is just
a draw em check I'm just calculating
very slowly at the moment 96 yeah this
was also on my mind and also wins okay
because this is really a neat win now
but 96 I wasn't really sure that
threaten 97 years mmm now you have many
attractive ways to win at the end at two
p.m. but it was based on a
miscalculation I thought that um oh the
now the nor the computer senses white is
winning okay how am i winning here oh
that's very cute h4 ones with the idea
rookie 3g three yeah i wouldn't have
found that i probably can't just check
given those checks and jump yeah night
f7 is this may be an idea attending
night h6 can do this
okay mmm interesting and he went to went
here and now the computer is giving g4
with the wide advantage okay this I
wasn't capable of and here black is
actually winning not with this but with
rook g8 yeah this is what I expected but
I still thought I should should have a
drink and don't have a draw with this
but ok he crawls all the way back yeah
mmm there is no perpetual check check
can just go back in no and this is
basically a self-made Queenie 7 and now
it is a chance of frost made qu shang
chat was nonsense i know i saw it
finally they actually can meet him yeah
so i'm glad that i have won a game
against the good player but Esther had a
very shaky performance alright thanks
for watching